before time in a world in a world where
bad impressions somehow or funny
[Music]
[Applause]
polytune Oh - mark okay when he gets
really sort of emotional he gets a
little bit more broken up the only
supposed to break those up body only
supposed to blow the bloody doors off I
just started a dying dog she's only 16
is that it yo nice but to be honest my
surprise body dozed off is that even a
you're talking to me you're talking to
me you're talking to me it's so bad Al
Pacino say hello to my little friend say
hello to my little friend
no that's a mama I'm trying to get arms
yeah I know oh my god I can't do that
Chewbacca that's still on Pacino I need
more chest there's not a furry beast
living inside of me I still have this
double I am your governor I will be back
I'll be back
get out less this is the reference to
okay Clint Eastwood do you feel lucky
punk if Clint Eastwood was a really sort
of campus trail Ian I mean do you feel
lucky punk why my Swinton I don't I
don't feel particularly lucky Oh Gollum
my precious my precious
does he have an English accent :
I'm Tina hurry Bob Ghostface from scream
what's your favorite scary movie
surprise
Sydney that was my best doing Wilson oh
oh wow wow wow wow oh wow I'm out
everyone's like stop digging pressures a
good thing I'm gonna be in trouble
thank you so grateful thank you so much
thank you
[Music]